indigenous strikers gathered outside of
quito's basilica reacting angrily to an
ultimatum issued by ecuadorian president
guillermo lasso
we will radicalize our strike we won't
leave quito without results long live
the struggle
[Music]
into the third week of a crippling
nationwide strike led by the
confederation of indigenous peoples it
appeared that negotiations with the
government inside the basilica were
making headway
but an overnight attack against a
military convoy escorting fuel from the
oil-rich amazonia region left one
soldier dead and 12 injured the
government blames the confederation's
leader leonidas issa who in turn
suggests it was the army that attacked
an indigenous community first
president lasso rushed to end the talks
we will not sit down again at the
negotiating table with leonidas issa who
only defends his own political interests
and not those of his union members
indigenous brothers you deserve better
than this opportunistic leader who has
deceived you and the entire country
the ultimatum is seen by many indigenous
communities as a declaration of war
we are going to resist until the last
consequences
we won't surrender if we have to die it
will be standing up not on our knees
while the national assembly prepared to
vote on a no-confidence vote against
lasso
the leader of the legislature appealed
to the president to return to the
negotiating table the president's
strategy is obviously to try to divide
the until now united indigenous strikers
but it seems unlikely that they will
want to turn their back on the
charismatic leonidas issa at least in
the short term
president lasso has refused to cave into
demands to lower fuel prices and repeal
a decree that expands mining in
indigenous regions
sooner or later the government will have
to understand that the situation is
unsustainable and give in the situation
of ungovernability here is dramatic
but lasso is remaining firm knowing full
well that in the last 26 years three
ecuadorian presidents have been forced
out with the help of the combative
indigenous movement
lucia newman al jazeera quito